TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE WILL
COME TO ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON
AND WELCOME. I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR BEING PATIENT WITH
OUR LATE START, WE SHOULD HAVE
AN EARLY FINISH, THOUGH, WE HAVE
13 MEASURES ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
AND WHEN THERE ARE SUFFICIENT,
MEMBERS WILL ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
IT LOOKS A LITTLE PREMATURE TO
DO THAT AT THE MOMENT. AND THE
ASSISTANT LET ME KNOW A GOOD
TIME TO DO THAT. WE WILL NEED AN
AUTHOR TO GET STARTED. I
UNDERSTAND, AND WE HAVE SOMEBODY
COMING IN THERE. HE IS RIGHT IN
FRONT OF ME. PERFECT. EXCELLENT
TIMING. AND SO WE WILL GO TO
FILE ITEM FIVE, AB 1904.
SOMEBODY MEMBER WARD. YOU'RE
WELCOME TO PRESENT WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. AND THANK YOU.
WELL, GOOD AFTERNOON, SENATORS,
FIRST, I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL. AB 1904 WOULD
GRANT TRANSIT AGENCIES WITH THE
AUTHORITY TO EQUIP TRANSIT
BUSSES WITH A FLASHING LED YIELD
RIGHT OF WAY, SIGN ON THE LEFT
REAR OF THE BUS, PROVIDING THE
AGENCY'S GOVERNING BOARD
PROVIDES A RESOLUTION TO ADOPT
THE SIGNAGE. THIS AUTHORITY
WOULD REDUCE TRAFFIC DELAYS
EXPERIENCED BY TRANSIT BUSSES
WHEN ATTEMPTING TO REENTER
TRAFFIC AND FACILITATE SAFER
REENTRY, ALLOWING OPERATORS TO
PROVIDE MORE TIMELY SERVICES FOR
WITNESSES. I HAVE IN SUPPORT
ALCHEMY GRAHAM, THE LEGISLATIVE
AND REGULATORY ADVOCATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION.
AND WHEN THE TIME IS
APPROPRIATE, I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, AND YOU MAY
PROCEED. YOU HAVE A COUPLE
MINUTES TO PRESENT. PERFECT.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, ALCHEMY. GRAHAM, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION, ON BEHALF OF OUR
MORE THAN 220 MEMBER
ORGANIZATIONS, I'M HERE TODAY TO
SUPPORT TO VOICE OUR SUPPORT FOR
AND PROUD CO-SPONSORSHIP OF AB
1904. MANY, IF NOT ALL OF US
HERE TODAY HAVE EXPERIENCED
SITTING IN TRAFFIC DIRECTLY
BEHIND A BUS WHILE THE OPERATOR
IS TRYING TO ATTEMPT ATTEMPTING
TO REENTER TRAFFIC FROM A
SCHEDULED STOP. I'M SURE WE'VE
ALL BEEN THERE. DRIVERS OFTEN
ATTEMPT TO PASS THE BUS RATHER
THAN SLOW DOWN OR STOP TO ALLOW
THE OPERATOR TO MERGE BACK INTO
TRAFFIC, AND IT CREATES UNSAFE
DRIVING CONDITIONS. WHILE
SEEMINGLY MINOR, THE IDLING TIME
CAN ADD UP VERY QUICKLY, LEADING
TO SIGNIFICANTLY DELAYED BUS
ARRIVALS ALONG THE SERVICE
ROUTE. IN 2001, PURSUANT TO THE
LAW AS ESTABLISHED BY AB 1218
ASSEMBLY, A FORMER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, KEELEY, THE SANTA CRUZ
METROPOLITAN TRANSIT DISTRICT
AND SANTA CLARA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
LAUNCHED PILOT PROGRAMS TO
DEBUTING FLASHING SIGNS ON THE
REAR OF THEIR BUSSES, AMONG
OTHER THINGS, THE PROGRAMS
CONCLUDED THAT THE YIELD SIGNS
WERE SIGNIFICANTLY BENEFICIAL IN
FACILITATING A SMOOTH REENTRY
INTO TRAFFIC AND PROMOTING SAFER
DRIVING CONDITIONS FOR BUS
OPERATORS. BUILDING OFF OF THESE
PILOT PROGRAMS, AB 1904 TAKES AN
IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD IN
PRIORITIZING PUBLIC TRANSIT BY
OFFERING OPERATORS AN ENHANCED
SENSE OF SAFETY WHEN NAVIGATING
CONGESTED ROADS AND HELPING
STREAMLINE BUS SERVICES. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO
WISHES TO COME UP AND EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL? PLEASE DO
SO. GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIR
MEMBERS ROSS BULKLEY, ON BEHALF
OF VENTURA COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT.
ANYONE ELSE WISH TO COME UP
UNDER THIS ME TOO SECTION IN
SUPPORT? AGAIN, THIS IS FILE
ITEM FIVE. WARD AB, 1904. I SEE
NO ONE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
COMING FORWARD, WE WILL ASK FOR
OPPOSITION, IS THERE A LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS? I DON'T DO
NOT BELIEVE WE HAVE A REGISTERED
OPPOSITION WITNESS, SEEING NONE.
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM WHO WISHES TO COME FORWARD
AND EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL, SEEING NONE, WE WILL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. BUT
BEFORE WE TAKE COMMITTEE
COMMENT, I'D LIKE TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM WHILE WE CAN. AND I'LL
ASK THE ASSISTANT TO CALL THE
ROLL, PLEASE. OKAY. SENATORS
CORTEZ HERE. DAISY. HERE. NILO
HERE. NILO HERE. ALAN. ARCHULETA
HERE. ARCHULETA. HERE. BECKER
BLAKE. SPEER. DALLY. DODD DODD
HERE. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. HERE.
LIMON NEWMAN. WHEN? WHEN HERE.
PORTANTINO SATO. SIERRA. HERE.
UMBERG. HERE UMBERG. HERE WE
HAVE. ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE A
QUORUM ESTABLISHED, WE'LL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AGAIN.
IT'S FOR ITEM FIVE, AB 1904,
SUMMER WARD. COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS? SENATOR ARCHULETA,
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. OBVIOUSLY, THERE'S SOME
ELEMENTS TO THIS. NUMBER ONE
BEING SAFETY, AND NUMBER TWO
OBVIOUSLY WOULD BE, NOT JUST THE
VEHICLES BEHIND THE BUS, BUT THE
BUS DRIVER ITSELF. AND THE OTHER
COURSE IS THE TIMING FOR THIS
AND MOVING THIS ALONG THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. SO IT'S OBVIOUSLY
VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE TAKE A
GOOD LOOK AT THIS. AND I'VE
STUDIED IT. AND IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT YOU'RE ON THE RIGHT TRACK.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE COST WILL
BE PER BUS. BECAUSE WE'RE GOING
TO DISSEMINATE THAT INFORMATION
TO THE OTHER TRANSIT AUTHORITIES
AS WE GO FORWARD. SO THERE'S A
FIGURE THAT WE'RE AWARE OF. I'M
SURE IT WOULD BE ABSORBABLE
AGAINST AT THE DISCRETION OF A
LOCAL AGENCY IF THEY WANT TO
ADOPT THIS BY ORDINANCE. AND IT
ALSO WOULD INCLUDE THE
REQUIREMENT THAT THEY DO A
PUBLIC OUTREACH CAMPAIGN. SO
PEOPLE ARE FAMILIAR WITH THIS
NEW SIGNAGE AND HOW TO RESPOND
TO IT. IF YOU HAVE A FIGURE.
YEAH. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION. SO IN THE NUMBERS THAT
WE HAVE SEEN IN THE IN THE
REPORTS THAT WE'VE SEEN FROM THE
PILOT PROGRAMS, WE'VE SEEN
ANYWHERE FROM ABOUT 250 PER BUS
TO ABOUT 600 PER BUS. I WILL SAY
THAT THOSE NUMBERS WERE BASED ON
WHEN THOSE PILOT PROGRAMS WERE
COMPLETED OR EXCUSE ME, LAUNCHED
IN 2001. SO THOSE NUMBERS COULD
BE DIFFERENT NOW, BUT I WILL
MIRROR WHAT THE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
JUST SAID THAT THIS DOES NOT AT
ALL REQUIRE THE AGENCIES TO
ADOPT THE YIELD SIGNS. IT MERELY
ALLOWS THEM TO DO SO. SO IF THEY
IF THEY WISH TO NOT TAKE ON
THOSE COSTS, THEY ALSO DO HAVE
THE OPTION OF INSTALLING STATIC
DECALS. SO THE FLASHING SIGNS
ARE A LITTLE BIT MORE EXPENSIVE
BECAUSE THEY'RE FLASHING LED
SIGNS. BUT THE STATIC DECAL
SIGNS ARE SIGNIFICANTLY LESS
EXPENSIVE. I DON'T HAVE AN EXACT
NUMBER FOR YOU. GOING BACK TO MY
POINT ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY AND SO
ON, BUT ALSO THE TIMING THAT
WE'RE TALKING, YOU KNOW, AND
SERVICE TO THE COMMUNITY. SO AS
WE MOVE ALONG, I'D LIKE TO MOVE
IT, AND I WILL BE SUPPORTING IT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR.
THANK YOU, SENATOR ARCHULETA.
WE'LL BE HAPPY TO GET THOSE
FIGURES FOR YOU FROM MY HOME
COUNTY AND THE VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY,
SENATOR SOURTOE. HI. THANK YOU,
I HAD A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
ABOUT. YOU TALKED ABOUT A STUDY.
SHE TALKED ABOUT A STUDY THAT
WAS DONE, WAS THERE ANY STUDIES
DONE ON ON DRIVER CONFUSION
ABOUT WHEN THIS. BECAUSE THIS
ISN'T A LAW, BUT JUST A SIGN
THAT SAYS YIELD. AND THAT'S KIND
OF WHAT THE TURN SIGNAL DOES TO
WHEN THEY PUT ON THEIR TURN
SIGNAL. YOU NOW KNOW THAT THIS
BUS IS ABOUT TO PULL OUT, AND
THEY SHOULD PROBABLY YIELD OR
WOULD BE A GOOD IDEA. WELL, THIS
DOESN'T DO ANYTHING MORE THAN
THAT OTHER THAN SAY, HEY, THEY
DO THE SAME THING AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT YOU'LL FIND IN A LOT
OF ACCIDENTS IS THAT CONFUSION
LEADS TO ACCIDENTS, AND, AND SO
WHEN YOU KNOW, TWO PEOPLE KIND
OF DON'T KNOW WHAT THE OTHER IS
GOING TO DO, THEY WIND UP
RUNNING INTO EACH OTHER. DID YOU
HAVE ANY DO YOU HAVE ANY STUDY
REYES AND, AND MAYBE, YOU KNOW,
QUESTIONS OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE
EXPERIENCED THIS, THESE SIGNS
THAT THEY SAID THERE WAS
ADDITIONAL CONFUSION? WELL, IF I
COULD ADD IN, THAT WAS IN OUR
ANALYSIS. THE CHP COMMISSIONED
STUDY FROM SANTA CLARA AND SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES AS WELL, NOTED THAT
WHEN THAT STUDY CAME BACK THAT
SHOWED THAT 60% OF THE
OPERATORS, THE TRANSIT BUS
OPERATORS, FELT THAT THERE WAS
SOME EFFECTIVENESS. AND THAT'S
FROM THE OPERATORS POINT OF
VIEW. AND THEN FROM SOME
NATIONAL STUDIES IN THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTH FLORIDA HAD
THEM MOVING THE BUS SAFELY BACK
INTO TRAFFIC. STUDY SHOWED THAT
WHEN THERE WAS ONLY A YIELD SIGN
THAT CARS YIELDED 41% OF THE
TIME, BUT IF THERE WAS A
FLASHING LED SIGN THAT THERE WAS
78% COMPLIANCE WHEN THEY ALLOWED
THEM TO BE ABLE TO COME BACK IN.
SO I THINK DRIVERS ARE
INTUITIVELY SEEING THAT AND KIND
OF AWARE, BECAUSE WE ARE
FAMILIAR WITH YIELD SIGNS ON THE
STREETS RIGHT OF WAY AND HOW TO
BE ABLE TO RESPOND TO THOSE. AND
SO THERE IS SORT OF A NATURAL
RESPONSE INSTEAD OF CONFUSION,
BUT IT DOESN'T MEAN THEY HAVE
TO. IT'S NOT A LAW THAT SAYS
THEY HAVE TO USE IT IS. THAT'S
CORRECT. IT'S NOT A CRIME. IT'S
NOT. I HOPE YOU YIELD. AND I PUT
MY SIGN OUT THERE. THERE SEEMS
TO BE SOME, YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT
OFTEN THAT WE ALWAYS GET, SOME,
YOU KNOW, NICE ACTIONS AS
OPPOSED TO ROAD RAGE ON THE
ROAD. BUT, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE SEEM
TO BE GETTING ALONG, SO IT'S A
GET ALONG THING. OKAY. THANK
YOU. IT'S HELPFUL. IT'S EVERYONE
STATING THEIR INTENT OF WHAT I'D
LIKE TO DO. AND THE BUS WOULD
LIKE TO REENTER TRAFFIC. THAT'S
SIGNAL. THAT'S TWO. YES. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE WANT TO QUESTION
THE AUTHOR OF THE WITNESS? I'M
SEEING NONE. SENATOR ARCHULETA
SAID HE WOULD MAKE THE MOTION.
MAKE THE MOTION? AND BEFORE WE
TAKE UP THE MOTION, WE'LL ALLOW
THE AUTHOR TO CLOSE. I'LL JUST
NOTE, YOU KNOW, WE'RE. I THINK
WE'RE ALWAYS TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WAYS COST EFFECTIVELY TO BE
ABLE TO IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY,
EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR TRANSIT
OPERATIONS. WE DO WANT TO GET
PEOPLE WHO ARE CHOOSING TO RIDE
TRANSIT OR NEED TO RIDE TRANSIT
FROM POINT A TO POINT B A LITTLE
BIT MORE EFFECTIVELY AND FASTER.
AND THIS IS ONE WAY THAT WE'RE
ABLE TO DO THAT, OR AT LEAST
AUTHORIZE AND ALLOW A LOCAL
AGENCY, THE, THE RIGHT TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THAT UNDER OUR
STATE STATUTE. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT
. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
WITH THAT, WE DO HAVE A MOTION,
AND WE'LL ASK THE ASSISTANT TO
CALL THE ROLL, PLEASE. THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE, AB 1904.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS SENATORS
CORTESE A, CORTESE A NILO NÓ.
NILO NÓ ALLEN ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER. DALLY. DODD DODD I
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I LIMÓN
NEWMAN. WHEN WHEN. NØ PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO I CIERTO CIERTO NØ
UMBERG I UMBERG I. 6 TO 3 ON
CALL. ALL RIGHT. THE VOTE IS 6
TO 3. WE'LL LEAVE THE BILL ON
CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE ARE.
GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM TWO
AB 1778, WHICH IS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CONNELLY'S BILL. AND WE'LL ASK
HIM TO COME FORWARD. IF YOU'RE
READY TO PRESENT, YOU CAN GET
STARTED AT ANY TIME. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS. AND I'LL BE JOINED BY A
COUPLE OF WITNESSES AS WELL.
GOOD AFTERNOON. I'D LIKE TO
START BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
AND STAFF FOR THEIR WORK AND
INPUT ON THIS BILL. I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. AB 1778 WOULD
AUTHORIZE MARIN COUNTY AND ITS
TOWNS TO ESTABLISH A VOLUNTARY
PILOT PROGRAM PROHIBITING
INDIVIDUALS UNDER THE AGE OF 16
FROM OPERATING CLASS TWO
ELECTRIC BICYCLES. IF AN
ORDINANCE OR RESOLUTION IS
PASSED, THE COUNTY MUST SUBMIT A
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE BY
JANUARY 1ST, 2028 THAT INCLUDES
TRAFFIC STOP AND CITATION DATA.
CLASS TWO E-BIKES CAN BE
OPERATED WITH THE HANDLEBAR,
HANDLEBAR THROTTLE ALONE AND DO
NOT REQUIRE PEDAL ASSIST WITH
THE SIMPLE THUMB PUSH ON A
HANDLE, A CLASS TWO E-BIKE CAN
GO FROM 0 TO 20 MILES. AN HOUR
IN JUST ABOUT 10S, WHILE CLASS
TWO E-BIKES ARE REGULATED TO GO
NO MORE THAN 20MPH, TOO OFTEN
THEY ARE MODIFIED BY USERS TO GO
HIGHER SPEEDS, ENSURING THAT
YOUTH ARE SAFE WHILE RIDING.
E-BIKES HAS BEEN A HIGH PRIORITY
OF THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY,
PHYSICIANS HAVE REPORTED THAT
INJURIES OF INDIVIDUALS INVOLVED
IN E-BIKE CRASHES ARE NOT JUST
WHAT WE WOULD ASSOCIATE NORMALLY
WITH BIKES, I.E. SCRAPED KNEES
AND BRUISED ELBOWS, BUT RATHER
THE KINDS OF INJURIES YOU WOULD
EXPECT TO SEE IN CRASHES
INVOLVING HIGHER SPEED VEHICLES
SUCH AS INTERNAL BLEEDING,
PELVIC FRACTURES, DAMAGE TO
VITAL ORGANS AND BRAIN TRAUMA.
RECOGNIZING THIS, LAST MONTH,
THE MARIN COUNTY GRAND JURY
ANNOUNCED THEIR DECISION TO
SUPPORT CREATING AN AGE LIMIT OF
16 TO OPERATE CLASS Dð E-BIKES
AND THAT ALL CLASS TWO E-BIKE
RIDERS SHOULD BE REQUIRED TO
WEAR A HELMET. BOTH PROVISIONS
ARE INCLUDED IN THIS BILL. ALL
AB 1778 IS NARROWLY TAILORED TO
ADDRESS POTENTIAL HAZARDS
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE BICYCLES
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. WE BELIEVE
THAT SETTING AN AGE LIMIT FOR
OPERATORS AND COLLECTING MORE
DATA ON THIS ISSUE WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE CRASHES AND
HELP ENSURE THAT OUR STREETS
REMAIN SAFE FOR EVERYONE. OUR
PRIORITY IS TO STRIKE A BALANCE
BETWEEN ENCOURAGING THE USE OF
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION AND
ENSURING THE SAFETY OF OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS, PARTICULARLY
OUR YOUNG RIDERS. SO I WILL NOW
PASS IT OFF TO MY WITNESSES,
DOCTOR JOHN MÀ, ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF SURGEONS,
AND AMELIA STAFFORD, STUDENT AT
TERRA LINDA HIGH SCHOOL IN SAN
RAFAEL, WHICH IS PART OF MY
DISTRICT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
CHAIR CORTEZ AND MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
I WAS THE 2013 PRESIDENT OF THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
SURGEONS. WE'VE BEEN JOINED BY
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CHAPTER,
AS WELL AS SAN DIEGO, AS THE
SPONSOR OF THIS LEGISLATION. I
ALSO SERVED AS THE 2018
PRESIDENT OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
MARIN MEDICAL SOCIETY, AND ALSO
A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION, WHO HAVE
BOTH ENDORSED THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION. SURGEONS STATEWIDE
HAVE GATHERED DATA REGARDING THE
HAZARDS OF E-BIKES, RESULTING IN
SERIOUS DISABILITY AND DEATH.
THIS FEBRUARY, UCSF RESEARCHERS
REPORTED A DRAMATIC 49 FOLD
INCREASE IN HEAD INJURIES
RELATED TO E-BIKE ACCIDENTS
NATIONALLY OVER THE PAST FIVE
YEARS IN MARIN, OUR RESEARCH HAS
SHOWN THAT E-BIKE RIDERS HAVE A
SIGNIFICANTLY GREATER RISK OF
DEATH COMPARED TO PEDAL
CYCLISTS. I'M HONORED TO YIELD
THE REMAINDER OF MY TIME TO MISS
AMELIA STAFFORD, WHO HAS
TRAVELED FROM SAN RAFAEL TODAY
WITH HER FAMILY TO SHARE HER
IMPORTANT STORY, WHICH WAS THE
INSPIRATION FOR ASSEMBLY BILL
1778, THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS OF
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF SURGEONS
APPLAUD HER COURAGE TO SHARE HER
STORY PUBLICLY, AND URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO VOTE AYE TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
CORTEZ AND MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS AMELIA STAFFORD AND I AM
A 15 YEAR OLD HIGH SCHOOL
SOPHOMORE. I'M HERE TO SHARE MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE. FIRST, I
WANT TO EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE TO
DOCTOR MÀ AND ALL THE SURGEONS
AND HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS AT
MARIN GENERAL CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL OAKLAND, UCSF MISSION
BAY, KAISER VALLEJO AND KAISER
OAKLAND. FIVE TEAMS AT FIVE
HOSPITALS WHO SAVED MY LIFE.
THEIR EXPERTISE AND CARE ARE THE
ONLY REASONS I AM ABLE TO STAND
BEFORE YOU TODAY. MY ACCIDENT
SHOWS HOW DEVASTATING A FALL
FROM A CLASS TWO E-BIKE CAN BE,
BUT MINE WAS JUST ONE OF MANY. I
AM HERE ON BEHALF OF VICTIMS WHO
CAN'T BE HERE TO TELL THEIR
STORIES. IMAGINE AN ORDINARY
SATURDAY NIGHT IN A SAFE
NEIGHBORHOOD. A GROUP OF TEENS
CASUALLY TAKING TURNS ON A NEW
E-BIKE FOR THE FIRST TIME.
FAMILIAR SURROUNDINGS CAN LEAD
TO A FALSE SENSE OF SECURITY.
THEY MIGHT NOT BE WEARING
HELMETS, EVEN IF THEY NORMALLY
DO WHEN GOING TO AND FROM SCHOOL
TO A TEENAGER. THESE BIKES SEEM
LIKE NORMAL BIKES. 20MPH DOESN'T
FAZE US. IT DOESN'T SOUND FAST
OR DANGEROUS, BUT THE REALITY IS
FAR DIFFERENT. FALLS FROM
E-BIKES ARE NOT LIKE FALLS FROM
NORMAL BIKES. THEY ARE FAR MORE
COMPARABLE TO VIOLENT FALLS FROM
MOTORCYCLES. I DON'T REMEMBER
ANYTHING FROM MY ACCIDENT OR
FROM THE FIRST TWO MONTHS I
SPENT IN ICUS. ALL AROUND THE
BAY AREA, ALTHOUGH I DON'T
REMEMBER. I KNOW MY FAMILY AND
FRIENDS HAD DOUBTS I'D EVER BE
BACK TO NORMAL, LIFT A FINGER,
OR EVEN SURVIVE. DURING THIS
TIME, I UNDERWENT THREE BRAIN
SURGERIES. THE FIRST SAVED MY
LIFE BY RELIEVING EXTREME
BLEEDING AND SWELLING THROUGH
THE REMOVAL OF A LARGE SECTION
OF MY SKULL. THE SECOND AND
THIRD SURGERIES SAVED MY LIFE
FROM INFECTIONS. FINALLY, AFTER
171 DAYS, A FOURTH AND FINAL
SURGERY RESTORED MY SKULL. NOW
NINE MONTHS LATER, I AM
BEGINNING TO MAKE UP FOR ALL THE
LOST TIME. EVEN WITH SOME OF THE
BEST MEDICAL CARE IN THE WORLD,
I AM STILL INCREDIBLY LUCKY. IF
THE SAME INJURY HAD OCCURRED ON
THE LEFT SIDE OF MY BRAIN
INSTEAD OF THE RIGHT, I'M TOLD I
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO GIVE THIS
STATEMENT HERE TODAY TO MY FIRST
RESPONDERS, DOCTORS, NURSES,
THERAPISTS, FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
I THANK YOU BECAUSE OF YOU, I AM
HERE AND BECAUSE OF WHAT I HAVE
LEARNED. I AM HERE TO SPEAK OUT
TO PROTECT TEENAGERS LIKE ME. I
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER CONNOLLY
FOR RAISING AWARENESS ABOUT THIS
ISSUE. I URGE THIS COMMITTEE TO
VOTE YES ON AB 1778. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR STEPPING FORWARD TO GIVE
THAT TESTIMONY. WE'RE GOING TO
ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
EXPRESS THE SUPPORT POSITION FOR
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. MR. CHAIR.
DYLAN ELLIOTT, ON BEHALF OF
MARIN COUNTY, PROUD CO-SPONSOR
AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR.
CHIARA ROSS, ON BEHALF OF THE
MARIN COUNTY COUNCIL OF MAYORS
AND COUNCIL MEMBERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
IS THERE A LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS ON THIS BILL? IF SO,
PLEASE COME FORWARD. SEEING
NONE, IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
EXPRESS AN OPPOSED POSITION TO
THE BILL? SEEING NO ONE COME
FORWARD, WE'RE GOING TO COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS. SENATOR DODD. YEAH,
I'D LIKE TO THANK, SENATOR,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CONNOLLY FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL. AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BUT
EVERYBODY THERE, BUT
PARTICULARLY YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY. THIS REALLY
SEEMS LIKE SOMETHING THAT'S SO
STRAIGHTFORWARD, SOMETHING THAT
WE NEED TO DO. AND I
PARTICULARLY LIKE THE WAY YOU'VE
CRAFTED, YOU KNOW, PENALTIES AND
JUST KIND OF LIKE THE LAST BILL
NOTWITHSTANDING, MAYBE THAT'S,
YOU KNOW, PART OF THE STAFF WORK
DONE HERE TODAY, BUT, I THINK
THIS IS A GREAT STEP FORWARD.
AND THANK YOU. I'LL BE VOTING
FOR IT TODAY. ANYONE ELSE ON THE
COMMITTEE? YES. SENATOR SEN
SEYARTO. THANK YOU. THESE E-BIKE
E-BIKES HAVE CREATED A LOT OF
CONCERN FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE, AND
THERE'S AN ACCUMULATION OF SOME
LAWS THAT WE'VE CHANGED IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS THAT HAVE MADE
THE PROPENSITY TO GET INJURED
EVEN WORSE, THE RIDING ON
SIDEWALKS, BLASTING THROUGH
INTERSECTIONS WITHOUT STOPPING,
ALL OF THESE, COMBINED WITH THE
ADVENT OF E-BIKES THAT GO A LOT
FASTER THAN KIDS, ARE NORMALLY
USED TO BEING ABLE TO PEDAL, AND
, YOU KNOW, FRANKLY, IF THE
PARENTS ARE THINKING THAT THAT'S
JUST A REGULAR BIKE THAT'S
EASIER TO PEDAL, IT'S NOT IT'S A
LITTLE MOTORCYCLE IS WHAT IT IS.
AND, AND SO THAT'S A GREAT
CONCERN, LAST YEAR WE WHEN WE
WERE GRAPPLING WITH SOME OF
THESE BILLS, WE HAD, ASKED THAT
THEY DO A STUDY TO TRY TO, GET A
HANDLE ON WHAT SHOULD BE DONE,
TO, TO DO THAT. AND IT SEEMS
LIKE WE'RE GETTING A LITTLE BIT
AHEAD OF THAT, AND I'M ANXIOUS
TO SEE WHAT THIS, YOU KNOW, THIS
STUDY IS, THEY SAY IT'S GOING TO
TAKE ANOTHER TWO YEARS AND IT'LL
BE IN 2026. WE'LL GET THE
RESULTS OF THIS STUDY, TO HELP
US GRAPPLE WITH THE NEW
REALITIES OF THERE'S E-BIKES OUT
THERE AND I'M HOPING AT THAT
TIME, WE'LL BE ABLE TO CRAFT, A
COMPLETE POLICY THAT WILL
ADDRESS SOME OF THE LAWS THAT
WE'VE ALREADY PASSED THAT I
THINK ARE ABSURD. AND ALSO, BE
ABLE TO PROTECT PEOPLE'S RIGHTS
TO ENJOY, YOU KNOW, SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT THEY GO OUT AND
ENJOY, LIKE, IF YOU'RE GOING OUT
ON AN E-BIKE WITH YOUR FAMILY,
YOU KNOW, MOM AND DAD AND THE
KIDS ARE ON VACATION DOING
E-BIKING, I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT
SHOULD BE BANNED. AND THAT
THAT'S CONCERNS ME. IS THERE A
CARVE OUT SO THAT PEOPLE CAN DO
THAT AS A FAMILY, OR MOM AND DAD
GOING TO GET A TICKET FOR
LETTING THEIR KIDS RIDE WITH
THEM ON A VACATION? THANK YOU.
SENATOR, SO REMEMBER, THIS IS
VERY NARROWLY TAILORED. WE'RE
ONLY TALKING ABOUT CLASS TWO
E-BIKES. SO THE SHALL WE SAY,
MORE TRADITIONAL PEDAL ASSIST
EBIKE, WHICH IS CLASS ONE, ALSO
UP TO 20 MILES AN HOUR IS NOT
COVERED BY THIS BILL, SO
CERTAINLY, UNDER THIS BILL AT
LEAST YOUTH OF ANY AGE WOULD
STILL BE ENABLED TO DO THAT.
RIGHT. AND ANY, ANY BIKES. WHAT.
SO ANYTHING WITH TWO WHEELS THAT
A KID UNDER 18 IS RIDING, THEY
HAVE TO HAVE A HELMET, CORRECT?
CORRECT. OKAY. SO THERE'S THE
HELMET LAW EXTENDS TO THIS
AUTOMATICALLY. WE DON'T NEED A
LAW WHERE THIS WOULD BE
DIFFERENT IS HELMETS WOULD BE
REQUIRED FOR ALL CLASS TWO
E-BIKE RIDERS IN MARIN COUNTY
FOR ADULTS AS WELL. CORRECT.
RIGHT. SO AND CURRENTLY IT'S
CLASS THREE AND ABOVE FOR
EVERYBODY. YES. BECAUSE CLASS
THREE IS CONSIDERED A MOPED
BASICALLY CLASS THREE THERE IS
CURRENTLY A HELMET LAW. AND
ACTUALLY VÆ A 16 YEAR OLD AGE
LIMIT AS WELL. SO THOSE ARE THE,
E-BIKES THAT CAN GO UP TO 28
MILES AN HOUR. SO THIS IS
BASICALLY TAKING A CLASS TWO,
ADDING THE CLASS OR CLASS THREE,
ADDING THE CLASS TWO TO IT IN
REGARDS TO 16 YEAR OLDS AND
UNDER. THAT'S A BASIC WAY OF
LOOKING AT IT. YES I'M A LITTLE
TORN BETWEEN THE, THE RIGHTS OF
PEOPLE TO ENJOY THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE DEVELOPING OUT THERE, BUT
AT THE SAME TIME, THE INJURIES
AS THIS YOUNG LADY HAS ATTESTED
TO OF, YOU KNOW, WHAT CAN HAPPEN
OUT THERE. AND WE CERTAINLY
ENDORSE A FIRST RESPONDER THAT'S
PRETTY YOU KNOW, THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT I TAKE, YOU KNOW,
VERY SERIOUSLY. ABSOLUTELY. AND
AS YOU POINTED OUT, THERE IS A
STATEWIDE STUDY PER CENT OF
MEN'S BILL THAT'S HAPPENING
THROUGH THE MINETA INSTITUTE.
AND WE ALL ARE, OF COURSE,
LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING THE
RESULTS OF THAT AS WELL. WE FELT
, AT LEAST ON A PILOT BASIS,
THOUGH, THE EVIDENCE IS
SUFFICIENT. OBERNOLTE AND THE
TYPE OF INJURIES WE'RE SEEING
SERIOUS ENOUGH THAT IT MAKES
SENSE TO GO FORWARD WITH THIS.
SO IT'S JUST A PILOT IN MARIN
COUNTY, CORRECT? ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU, SENATOR NEIL. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. I RIDE A BIKE
MYSELF FOR EXERCISE AND HAVE
FOR, QUITE A FEW YEARS, AND I'VE
TAKEN TWO OVER THAT TIME PERIOD
TO PRETTY SERIOUS SPILLS, AND IF
I WASN'T WEARING A HELMET, I
THINK I WOULDN'T BE HERE RIGHT
NOW. SO I SUSPECT YOU WERE NOT
WEARING A HELMET THAT YOU
PROBABLY WON'T DO THAT AGAIN,
THAT'S AN UNFORTUNATE WAY TO
LEARN THAT LESSON. BUT, I, I
DON'T QUESTION REQUIRING HELMETS
FOR KIDS. I DO A LITTLE BIT FOR
ADULTS, BUT I THINK I SHOULD
HAVE THE RIGHT TO RIDE A BIKE
WITHOUT A HELMET IF I WANT TO BE
THAT STUPID. I WOULDN'T, BUT
BUT, SINCE THIS AND IF I
UNDERSTOOD WHAT YOU SAID BEFORE
IN THE CLASS, THREE HELMETS ARE
REQUIRED FOR EVERYBODY. YES.
LIKE A MOTORCYCLE. YEAH. SO IT
WOULD BE INTERESTING. IT'LL BE
INTERESTING TO SEE, IF THIS BILL
PASSES, IS, OVER THIS PERIOD OF
TIME, WHAT THE EXPERIENCE IS
WITH REGARD TO HEAD INJURIES
PRIOR TO THE PASSAGE OF THIS
BILL AND AFTER THE PASSAGE, THE
ONE CONCERN I HAVE ABOUT THE
STATISTICS THAT THE DOCTOR CITED
IS YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A PERIOD
DURING WHICH E-BIKES HAVE JUST
BEEN EVOLVING. SO YOU WOULD
EXPECT TO SEE THE PERCENTAGE OF
ACCIDENTS INCREASE BECAUSE, YOU
KNOW, SIX, EIGHT YEARS AGO,
THERE WEREN'T E-BIKES. SO, IT'LL
BE INTERESTING TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS WITH REGARD TO THAT, FOR
ADULTS WITH THE CLASS TWO,
E-BIKES. BUT I WILL SUPPORT THIS
BECAUSE IT IS, I THINK,
IMPORTANT TO TREAT UNDERAGE KIDS
WITH THE CLASS TWO THE SAME AS
WE DO WITH THE CLASS THREE. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU, SEE? NO OTHER
REQUESTS. SENATOR ARCHULETA, DID
YOU WANT TO MAKE THE MOTION ON
THIS? YEAH, I'D LIKE TO MAKE A
MOTION, BUT ALSO, I'VE GOT. I'M
ASSUMING THIS IS YOUR MOTHER,
RIGHT. AND AS HERE, WE'VE GOT
PARENTS WITH KIDS THAT ARE VERY
YOUNG, AND WE'VE GOT PARENTS
WITH KIDS THAT ARE ALREADY IN
COLLEGE AND MARRIED, AND WE'VE
GOT THE WHOLE GAMUT HERE. BUT TO
SIT THERE AND HAVE YOUR CHILD
NEXT TO YOU, KNOWING THE
SUFFERING THAT YOU AND YOUR
FAMILY AND EVERYONE HAVE DONE
MONTH AFTER MONTH, AND TO BE
HERE, WHAT A WHAT AN INSPIRATION
YOU ARE. BUT THANK GOD YOUR
DAUGHTER IS FINE. SHE'S HERE AND
WHAT A GREAT PRESENTATION. AND I
THINK YOU NEED NOW TO GET TO THE
TO THE SCHOOL BOARDS AND JUST
SPREAD THE WORD, BECAUSE I KNOW
EVERYONE HERE IS IMPRESSED. AND
I KNOW IF WE WERE A SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS, WE WOULD BE IMPRESSED
AND, AND JUST GOT TO LET THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA KNOW, WHAT
THE DANGERS ARE OUT THERE. SO
THE MOTION IS THERE AND I WILL
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU.
SENATOR SO SENATOR ARCHULETA IS.
PUT A MOTION ON THE TABLE AND WE
THANK HIM FOR HIS COMMENTS.
AGAIN, WE THANK THE WITNESSES
VERY MUCH FOR AND FAMILY FOR
BEING HERE. AND WE'LL TURN TO
THE AUTHOR TO CLOSE AT THIS
POINT. THANK YOU. APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT,
THE MOTION IS BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA, AND WE'LL ASK THE
ASSISTANT TO CALL THE ROLL AT
THIS TIME. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO, AB 1778. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED. SENATOR
CORTESE. AYE. CORTESE. AYE. NILO
MILLO. AYE ALLEN. ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE. BECKER BLAKE.
SPEAR. DALLY. DODD. AYE DODD.
AYE. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE.
LIMON LIMON. AYE. NEWMAN A
NEWMAN. AYE. WHEN WHEN? AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
SATO. SATO. AYE. UMBERG. UMBERG
AYE. NHIÀU. BECKER. SEN. BECKER
AYE. BECKER. AYE. 12 ZERO ON
CALL. ALL RIGHT. THE VOTE IS 12
TO 0. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL
HERE FOR A BIT FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. AND WE THANK YOU AGAIN
VERY MUCH, ASSEMBLYMEMBER. AND
TO THE WITNESSES AND FAMILY,
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. WE
WILL GO TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR. AT
THIS TIME, WE HAVE 11 MEASURES
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT TODAY, I'M
GOING TO ASK THE ASSISTANT TO
READ OFF THE CONSENT ITEMS, AND
THEN WE CAN ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR,
INCLUDING AB 1774, AB 1953, ACR
158 AB 1924, AB 2111 AB 2261, AB
2536, AB 2634, AB 2812 ACR 124
SCR 143. ALL RIGHT. IS THERE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
MOVED MOVED BY SENATOR UMBERG,
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS CORTESE. CORTESE. AYE.
NILO. NILO. AYE. ALAN ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA. AYE. BECKER. BECKER.
AYE BLAKE. SPEER. DALLY. DODD.
DODD AYE. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ.
AYE. LIMÓN LIMON. AYE. NEWMAN.
WHEN I WHEN I PORTANTINO. I KNEW
HER GRANDFATHER. PORTANTINO. I
NEWMAN. I SATO, I SATO I UMBERG
I UMBERG I. YEAH. YOU'RE OKAY.
WE GOT TO LIFT THE CALL. 12
ZERO. GOOD WORK. ALL RIGHT.
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT ON A 12
ZERO VOTE. I'M GOING TO NOTE
THAT SENATORS DOLE AND
BREAKSPEAR ARE NOT COMING BACK.
AND THEREFORE THE PREVIOUS ITEM,
AB 1778. CONNOLLY, IS ALSO OUT
ON A 12 TO 0 VOTE WITH THE OTHER
TWO MEMBERS NOT RETURNING TO
VOTE TODAY. AND WE WILL LIFT THE
CALL ON ITEM FIVE AT THIS TIME.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE,
AB 1904. CHAIR VOTING AYE. VICE
CHAIR VOTING NO. SENATORS ALLEN
BECKER, BECKER I BLAKE SPEAR.
DALY LIMÓN. LIMÓN I NEWMAN.
NEWMAN I. HÌNH TWO THREE OUT.
AND THAT FINAL VOTE IS 9 TO 3,
AGAIN WITH TWO MEMBERS ABSENT
AND NOT RETURNING. THAT BILL IS
OUT. SURE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
EVERYONE. THAT CONCLUDES OUR
PROCEEDINGS FOR TODAY. WE
APPRECIATE AGAIN ALL THE WORK BY
THE COMMITTEE STAFF WHO DID A
YEOMAN'S JOB OF NOT ONLY DEALING
WITH, WITH, ANALYSIS AND
AMENDMENTS AND SO FORTH, BUT
GETTING US AN AGENDA TODAY THAT
WAS VERY WORKABLE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT. AND WE'LL
SEE EVERYONE AT THE NEXT SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
MEETING. WE'RE ADJOURNED.